let's give tick-tock some love let's not
just hate on social media let's not hate
on the people social media some people
on tick tock are doing some pretty good
things right so something's interesting
is going on on tick tock when's the last
time you're on tick tock oh i don't
really use stick talk i
but recycled tick tocks on like
instagram okay that's what i do i know
people hate that all right well there's
different types of tick tocks there's
like
dancing shake your ass tick tock right
right there's like
recipe learn how to cook tick tock
financial tick and there's financial
tick tock thank you you're on the ball
bro i'm sorry call me to steal your
thing no you're stealing it take it take
it
dave cass coming soon there it is
um but there's finance tick tock so get
this story
tick-tockers
are trading stocks by copying what
members of congress do this is the npr
story yeah we talked about this on the
pbd podcast yes we're gonna go a little
bit deeper though bro okay all right all
right all right so young investors have
a new strategy on tick tock you got this
thing yeah there it is um i got that
thing you know i used to think that tick
tock was just
bingo but that's not all it is there's
some investing stuff going on there's
some finance stuff there's some business
stuff going there's some political stuff
oh i'm about to tell you about it
so young investors have a new strategy
right tick tock bro tick tock tick tock
um they watch the financial disclosures
from members of congress this is so for
stock tips right they'll get this for
stock tips i was thinking
all right and they because they're
suspicious of this right they're super
suspicious that they got some insider
trading stuff going on they're making
moves with these inside stuff going on
so they but but here's the reality
here's the reality of this so thanks to
a lot called the stock act appropriately
named stock act lawmakers and their
spouses
must disclose stock trades within 45
days after making a trade so oh you
think you're just going to do some
insider trading now you got to disclose
it all right so that's how you always
hear about these how did how did this
guy made this trade
uh as a congressman uh burr
from from north carolina he got into hot
water not too long ago for oh you made
some oh i saw that you approved this uh
funding bill for the army and then you
uh
invested in uh defense contract bill
okay we got you buddy all right so it
has to be disclosed that's how these
things find out so there's a guy on tick
tock his name is chris joseph let's get
a shout out to this guy he might watch
this repost his tick tock and you never
know uh so he's the co-founder of a
company called iris which shows other
people's stock trades basically saying
all right this person's doing that this
person's doing that huh so on this
social media investing platform iris you
can get a push notification every time a
congressman or congresswoman's stock
trading disclosures are released so
joseph's came up with this idea this guy
chris josephs he's like all right cool
like i see what's going on i'm trying to
get on the come up right here i see all
this what a ditch what a niche what a
niche the niches you know riches are in
the niches so he noticed that that uh
he's like all right this is this pelosi
was what's this pelosi deal she's got
this husband all right let me follow
this what's going on there so basically
he started following nancy pelosi's
trades or her husband's trades because
again you have to disclose yours and
your spouse's trades he notices the
trades that have been made by uh
pelosi's husband were performing very
well
okay so he's like
[Music]
what's going on here so he says he
personally invests any time he sees the
stocks which they pick he says quote
unquote i'm at the point where if you
can't beat him
join him
you know it you know mitch mcconnell
and his wife elaine chao they're
investing in chinese stocks buy
right it's not just the democrats
republicans they're all doing it right
so so far this year this is according to
the stats so far this year
the senate and house members right two
members of uh congress sent in the house
they've filed more than 4 000 financial
trading disclosures meaning they're
trading bro yeah with at least 315
million in stocks and bonds bought or
sold
okay so while they're you know not
passing laws in congress and wasting all
our time and spending money they're
getting themselves rich this is how they
do it but they have to disclose it yeah
okay we have someone in the chat that's
sv time chaser i've been trading nancy's
trades wow tell us how that's been
telling i've been trading ninja trades
let's let's work it out for you how's
that going what are they trading what's
the deal with that so they say that this
is not insider trading but quote unquote
insider knowledge
look i'll give you my opinion on this if
it's not illegal okay is it frowned upon
i don't know
uh can you copy what they do for sure i
don't think there's anything wrong with
that yeah why not this is not a left or
right thing
this is a money thing oh my god this
guy's on fire
how about this this isn't a red or a
blue thing
it's a green thing
you're on fire today dave cass field
what is going on here
it's insane you're on fire right now so
anyway shout out to this guy chris
josephs iris
where you can find out what nancy pelosi
mitch mcconnell these members of
congress are doing with their trades
anyway
uh not a left or right thing
it's a money thing yeah not a red or
blue thing it's a green thing this guy's
on fire right now thank you david
um
you know what time it is right now
what's up
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
size cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken